this is a job that is done by taste
and sometimes my floor is a little not that
they are not as simple as jar as they
can seem welcome to the hospital
of dolls
[Music]
I have been the general practitioner of this hospital
for about 30 years  years
we have the hospital where only
gumex are treated not people
the hospital is already in the family and the
interactions
I started in 1830 and until today we have
continued when the dolls come in we
down there in the store we make the diagnosis
just like the hospital the series fill in
a  form and then we go on living what
they need
we have the plastic surgery room
we also have a delay where
our organ donors are
we use a lot of things even from
serious surgery the years think of exams turin the
eyes is perhaps the most
frequent disease they have  vap is perhaps one of the
most fun things for kids to
spoil because just leaving and
picking them up and every year we have a lot of
religious images but the vast majority
- the poor took it out.  to restore
always a lot when they are ready they
will wait for them to come and vote it is not the
hospital that is important it is the people
who come here with us it is important
that we welcome the
memories when we deliver the goals
often people don't even  a tear
of pleasure from one of the child time soldiers
and they get quite emotional
of them take care of us much more
than we take care of them
[Music]